hello there friend my name is Greg I'm
talking with you today because
collider.com
has put out an article about a certain
video that is called something I don't
remember the title of this super cop
try not to say super [ __ ] this super cut
will make you jump 40 greatest movie
jump scares by burglar fiction now I've
seen some jump scare videos whatever
they don't really get me sometimes they
really do it's a little darkly lit in
here today because I wanted to keep it a
little spooky I don't even have the fan
blowing on me to keep me nice and cool
I'm a sweater I sweat I'm gonna wear
headphones today let's [ __ ] do this
turn off the lights put on heads you
know what okay there's gotta be a way to
make this even darker in here hold on
hello are you getting even TV now wrong
way oh yes way dark now got a
legitimately scared do this turn off the
lights put on headphones full blast make
this full stream good luck right
everyone shut up that was loud
oh insidious I know this one cool still
makes me really uncomfortable oh this
got me so much into theaters
it's kind of nerve-racking I don't know
this one
this wreck
I like this movie I liked you to bring
her out forgot about that
oh whoa sorry God that surely is a
terrifying moment
I totally forgot Thomas Jane was in that
like how there's too Sam Jackson deaths
in her
I just saw this not long ago sister
dan is still like five minutes left or
this [ __ ] oh it's definitely scarier
with headphones are the first time I saw
that has you freaked me out
Oh
i weirdly had a crush on that girl this
is a scariest move this is like it's
movie terrified me growing up it was PG
for some reason
oh is that ah I forgot the name of that
you don't [ __ ] with the Freddie and the
Carrie that's
I hate this oh you [ __ ] Japanese
horror flicks I freaked out John so much
got these filters so much better than
The Hobbit films
so girl seven men
ah very scared
oh the benzene signs
yeah I never saw the woman in black
right now that's this
oh is this a [ __ ] Marlin yes what's
called not good Oh what is this movie
ah
or the orphanage took an ash computer la
is so beautiful
nice
Wow
I don't be David
better this burger friction kids put
some lights all up in here boy I was
[ __ ] terrified it's fine man
dude burger fiction did awesome [ __ ]
job man
I gotta say dude like the fact that you
like took so much time to put something
like this together I can imagine the
amount of notes you have to take the
amount of like okay reflecting or just
going about your day like I wonder how
you like crafted this together I don't
know if you just sat down or threw out a
week span or whatever you kind of just
took notes and there's so many different
ways to be creative about this it's cool
he chose like some great jump scares
like these are not cheap jump scares
I've seen jump scare compilations but
usually they don't work because they're
not in the full context of the whole
scene you knew what prior moment to cut
to and leading up to the jump scare to
allow me to like feel it or some of
those were I saw the movie already but I
forgot about them and then there's some
where I did not see that movie oh dude
that was a quite fun man and you're
clearly a horror enthusiast
I like how not all the movies were
horror films like yeah I see I remember
how like The Dark Knight in there yet
pee-wee Herman in there in order for
this to be effective yeah you do need
lights off or at least lights dim and
you do need headphones on full-blast you
need be like invested in your computer
and order for it to be effective cuz
we're just watching from a distance you
know I could see like of it look at
these comments yeah a lot of these
people clearly didn't actually obey the
rules of your video my friend don't
listen to the haters I appreciate you
guys going on this journey with me I
know it doesn't make the same experience
for you just watching me do that as
opposed to you just doing it yourself
but I suppose it was worth your time
listen if you're new to this channel
subscribe to day become a reject and if
you want you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter links and description
box my friend